so we are off to vacation for my
birthday i'm almost unpacking the uber
is already on its way i'm
not ready as usual of course i'm
vlogging see you guys at the airport
unless i forget the film
so
i like when i travel i look homeless
it's like
look at you just planning our activities
i'm
your seat backs are excited the full
upright position all right so we're
boarding our next plane and
we it's really hot actually we were in
the little waiting area oh my god this
woman she was like flipping out she's
like where did you come from like you're
wearing loads she's honestly just like
that she came in first and she was fine
but then she went out and had a couple
of drinks so she was wasted nice she
came back and she was very chatty okay
we gotta get on there's our plane
okay bye
area
we're here we finally made it i don't
remember if i filmed this landing i
don't i feel like it blacked out the
entire trip here i'm really excited
about my shirt though the future is
coming soon
i'm a big fan i love it i love it
around